a big part of this show and correct me
if I'm wrong but it seems to be that you
are tackling how this young generation
communicates now and how much of it is
through text how much of it's through
email and things like that and that's so
important to dating now well I think
these days you need to have a lot of
text game and I have no text game
whatsoever it's really hard for me to
send a sexy text or definitely not a
sext but not a sexy text so I like
what's an example of what you trying to
be sexy on a text and it just didn't
work there's one that sort of famous
among my friends I was I mean I don't
really drink sometimes I try to make it
sound like I drink cuz I think it's what
like funky young people do but I myself
so I'm usually can be found in my house
or like eating like a probiotic
probiotic yogurt beverage of some kind
yeah not for those and you get a little
whacked out so this guy sent me a text
saying what are you gonna be doing later
and I was at home writing they said home
writing now but you can find me having a
few drinks to lubricate my situation why
would you say that yeah yeah yeah that's
not what you meant to say really right
no and did you hear back from him no I
didn't hear back from him then I heard
back from them a few weeks later asked
me if I could help him get tickets just
something
but then in terms of flirting [ __ ] I
never know when to stop so it's like
recently a guy sent me attack saying
your faces been following me everywhere
and I think that he was referring to the
billboards there's a lot of billboards
all over the place yeah there are at the
moment which has been really interesting
but I so I wrote back I thought you'd
like that and then immediately
afterwards I was like that was it right
what I just did so then I wrote back you
know that was a joke I have no idea if
you like looking at my face I have no
idea how you even feel about my face I'm
so sorry that I wrote that two minutes
later having still not heard from you I
was like if you want you can come by for
a drink later I have a couple male
friends staying on an air mattress in my
apartment I don't know if that's an
interest of yours don't really know you
at all and then yeah that was just